URS HOELZLE: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to Google I/O and the
Cloud Session at Google I/O.
I'm Urs Hoelzle.
I run technical infrastructure
at Google.
And let me start by talking a
little bit about the history
of our infrastructure.
We started building our internal
infrastructure a long
time ago, over a decade ago.
And we had to start building
it, because there wasn't
really any infrastructure that
scaled to the demands of our
workload, to Search, to Gmail,
to apps, to everything.
And last year, I invited Steven
Levy to come by and
have a look at our
infrastructure.
And he called it "the mother
of all clouds,"
which is kind of true.
Because we'd been working
on it for 14 years.
So for 14 years, we've been
building the largest, fastest,
and most cost effective
infrastructure in the world.
For over a decade, we've been
building our servers we've
been building our data centers,
we've been building
our networks.
You use this infrastructure
everyday, probably, because
you use Google products.
And so you know how fast
and reliable it is.
And building such an
infrastructure is really a
huge task and, sometimes,
it's a huge headache.
But for me and my team,
it's a huge challenge.
And that's what makes us get
up in the morning, come to
work, to go and make that
infrastructure even better.
And with the Google Cloud
infrastructure, you can now
use that same infrastructure
for your own applications.
But before we get into the
details, let me just show you
a few pictures of how
this actually looks.
Here's what looks like a room of
servers, but it's actually
from our networking room.
Our networking rooms are
larger than some other
people's server rooms.
Here's another look at a
networking room where we
connect our data centers
together.
Here's a row of servers, each
server built by us and
optimized for performance
and cost.
So maybe they're not
pretty, but they're
fast and very effective.
Here's the inside
of a server row.
So on both sides, you see
the back of the servers.
They push their hot air into
this plenum, where it gets
cooled again.
Here's a server room in Finland,
where we converted a
paper mill into a data center.
And here's a mechanical room,
in one of our data centers,
where all the cooling water
comes together.
Blue pipes deliver the cool
water to the floor.
Red is the warm water
coming back.
And here's some cooling towers
in the data center.
We use cooling towers, where
we evaporate water, to call
our data centers in an
environmentally friendly way.
In fact, we spent a lot of
effort to make our data
centers, an our cloud,
as environmentally
compatible as possible.
So we've been leaders
in data center
efficiency, for example.
Our data centers use only half
as much energy as normal,
average data centers.
And that's good not just for
the environment, it's also
good for you.
Because less overhead
means less cost.
And we pass these savings on
to you in lower prices.
We're also the first internet
company that's gotten ISO
14,000 environmental
certification for our
standards at the data centers.
And we're proud to have been
the Cool IT leader in the
Greenpeace Leader Board for
two years in a row now.
So when you run your
applications in the Google
Cloud, you know you're not
just getting great
performance, but you also
get great environmental
performance.
And we're continuing to build
this infrastructure.
Just in the last 12 months,
we announced data center
expansions, in the US, in
Europe, in Asia, and in South
America, for over
$2.9 billion.
So clearly we see a
lot of growth and
demand for our services.
But we also wanted to make sure
there's enough room for
the growth of your services.
We also run one of the world's
largest networks.
We're the only company, that's
not an ISP, to own and
operates submarine cables,
for example.
So here you see some pictures
of the Unity cable, where we
organized the consortium to
build a new cable between the
US and Japan that, today, serves
several terabits of
capacity between those two
places, just in time for for
"Gangnam Style", I guess.
So our network spans
the globe.
And it includes one of
the largest, if not
the largest, CDN.
We peer with virtually every
major ISP worldwide.
So we can hand off your bits to
the end user's ISP in one
step and, therefore, have the
best performance and speed.
So you know that you're not
just getting the best
performance inside
the data center.
You're also going to get the
best performance between data
centers and to your users.
And our network is
not just big.
It's also one of the most
advanced networks you'll find.
Well, today, many are talking
about introducing software
defined networking.
We have been running a software
defined backbone for
over two years.
Our OpenFlow powered backbone,
which you see here, connects
our data centers and provides
much better performance and
cost than our previous
backbone.
And so when you run your
application, on the Google
Cloud, you'll benefit from
that backbone as well.
And of course, we work
not just on physical
infrastructure but also on
software infrastructure.
And I'm especially proud that
we can really claim the best
track record, of any company,
in building
infrastructure software.
Here's just a few examples from
the last decade or so.
In 2002, we built GFS, the
Google File System.
And here, this was really the
first file system to scale to
data center size.
We had to build it, because no
existing file system could
really handle our workload.
Remember, to build a Web Search,
you have to first
build an index.
And to build an index, you have
to store your own copy of
the web in a file system.
So that's why we built GFS,
which, a few years later,
inspired Hadoop File
System, HGFS.
But we're not actually
using GFS anymore.
We moved on to Colossus,
which is it's much
more capable successor.
And that's what's actually
powering the cloud storage
today and also, pretty much, any
other storage at Google.
Now why did we retire what,
arguably, was one of the
world's most successful and
most capable file systems?
It's because we're building
for the future.
And we wanted a file system that
was more capable, a file
system that can handle workloads
and storage pools at
least 100 times bigger than GFS,
a file system that has
higher availability, with
multimaster and a fully
distributed directory, a file
system that understands
Flash and so on.
We also learned a lot of things
in the 13 years since
we started using GFS.
And all of these things have
flowed into Colossus.
And therefore, we retired GFS.
For another example, 2004 we
created MapReduce, which, of
course, inspired Hadoop and the
whole big data industry.
Similarly, here, we have a lot
of MapReduce still running
inside the company.
But we're not actually using
MapReduce anymore.
We use Flume, which makes it
much easier to construct large
pipelines of MapReduces.
In 2006, we created Big Table,
which is, probably, the
world's most scalable NoSQL
infrastructure and, very
likely, the most battle tested
NoSQL infrastructure there is.
Almost everything at Google uses
Big Table, so Gmail, web
indexing, G+, if they
use a NoSQL system.
So pretty much everything
runs on Big Table today.
But of course, we're already
working on making it obsolete.
And last year, we talked about
Spanner, which gives you a
similarly scalable and similar
performance system but with
transactional consistency.
So if hope you're catching
my point.
Not just once, but several
times, we wrote an industry
leading system, a decade ago,
only to retire it, because it
wasn't good enough anymore, and
we wanted to get something
even better.
And so we've been around the
block more than once.
And that's what you actually
see in the quality and the
performance of the public
cloud infrastructure.
Even though it's just
not even a year old.
So we spent the last 14 years
building these great systems,
with the scale, performance,
and value that we needed
internally.
And now we're making them
available to you.
In fact, in just the last 10-11
months, since I was here
at Google I/O announcing our
cloud, we've launched over 160
improvements to pretty
much all of the
systems in the cloud.
Now let's take a look at
what our users have
done with that cloud.
MapR broke the Minute Sort,
for only $1,200,
using Compute Engine.
The previous world record was
held by custom hardware
costing hundreds of thousands
of dollars.
So even in a prerelease
software, we're delivering
world record performance.
Snapchat, probably one of the
largest, fastest growing,
consumer services out there, is
delivering over 150 million
snaps per day on Google
App Engine.
Songpop scaled to over 80
million users on a cloud
platform, 1 million daily users,
using App Engine and
Datastore and cloud storage.
Scalr, the performance of
Compute Engine let Scalr dream
about things that they couldn't
dream about before,
even though they'd been
providing systems management
software for many other
cloud providers.
The simplicity of our
infrastructure lets Udacity
focus on doing courseware rather
than being an sysadmin
or dealing with administering
the systems.
And for those of you watching
from Europe, or here from
Europe, you know that the
"Concours Eurovision" is one
of the largest TV events in
the world, a song contest.
And just two days ago,
the semifinals ran.
And the software, for the user
participation in those
semifinals, was written by our
two partners, Scalr and
grandcentrix.
They delivered 50,000 requests
per second at really great and
consistent latency on
Compute Engine.
So our customers are using,
really, all parts of our
infrastructure.
Let's take a quick step
back and look at that.
Our Cloud Platform is a
comprehensive, integrated
platform, with compute, storage,
and application
services, and extension of our
internal infrastructure, with
strong connections to other
Google services and APIs.
And so as thousands of Google's
engineers improve
this infrastructure, for Google,
you will benefit from
those improvements as well.
So you can use what we use.
So you can build your software
and run your business, in the
same place that we do, with the
same performance, scale,
and value that we built
for ourselves.
So now that you've seen our past
and our vision, let me
show you a few things that
we're announcing today.
Let's start with Compute Engine,
because many of you
want and need access
to raw VMs.
That's important.
We announced Compute
Engine a year ago.
And we've rolled out a ton of
improvements since then.
Now, today, the standard unit
of measure for compute is an
hour, regardless of how much
time you actually use.
So if you have a 15 minute
job, that's done after 15
minutes, you still pay for 60
minutes, which increases your
actual cost by four times.
So just think about that,
imagine making at 15 minute
phone call, and you get charged
for a full hour.
It makes no sense.
And starting today, you won't
get overcharged like that on
Compute Engine.
We're introducing sub-hour
billing, which means that
you'd have the value and the
flexibility that you'd want
from the cloud.
And specifically, we're
billing in one minute
increments, with a 10
minute minimum.
So you really pay only for
what you actually use.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
URS HOELZLE: Thank you.
So sub-hour billing really
changes how you can think
about building your
applications.
So suppose you have a MapReduce,
and it's running
for an hour, and that's
too slow.
And suppose you want to make
it complete in 15 minutes.
Well, it's easy, just add four
times as many servers.
You get charged for four times
as many servers but only for
15 minutes.
So you end up paying basically
the same thing as before, yet
your job runs four
times faster.
In other cloud providers, you'd
have to pay a four times
premium for that extra speedup,
which really doesn't
make it a viable choice.
So the sorting world record,
that you saw before, now,
instead of $1,200,
only costs $200.
So that's really value,
performance, and scalability
all in one place.
But sometimes you need only a
little bit of VM, maybe for
testing or for an application
that just doesn't
need a lot of CPU.
So we're introducing smaller
micro-instances.
They're very cost effective
ways to
handle these workloads.
But unlike other provider's
small instances, these
instances still have predictable
performance, not
just best effort performance.
So just as sub-hour billing lets
you scale up a workload,
these instances let you scale
it down with predictable
performance.
We also have advanced routing
that lets you connect your
on-premise infrastructure,
with an
encrypted VPN, to the cloud.
It's very easy to use,
very straightforward.
Now you can have applications
that really span both
infrastructures.
Persistent disks are a big
portion of the value in the
infrastructure.
You want to attach persistent
disks to your VMs.
And our persistent disks are
limited to 1 terabyte, which,
even though it matches what
other providers have, isn't
really enough.
And so we were asked to
make them bigger.
And you were right.
1 terabyte isn't really
big enough.
So starting today,
you can have 10
terabyte persistent disks.
And I'm especially proud that
we've are introducing this 11
months after we started, after
we first announced Compute
Engine, where other leading
providers, after seven years,
have not managed to have
persistent disks
larger than 1 terabytes.
So speaking of storage, if
you've been using App Engine,
you loved Datastore, because
Datastore is, basically, Big
Table, a NoSQL data store that
is very, very scalable and
very, very easy to use.
So the App Engine high
replication Datastore has been
incredibly popular.
This Datastore, today, serves
over 4.5 trillion
transactions per month.
That's trillion not billion.
So it's been incredibly
successful.
It's twice the load that it
handled, less than 11 months
ago, at Google I/O.
And now you can use this
Datastore, from anywhere, as a
service, the Google
Cloud Datastore.
So whether you build your
application on App Engine or
on Compute Engine or
elsewhere, you
can access this Datastore.
And because it's NoSQL, it has
fast queries response time, no
matter whether you have
a 10K row table or a
10 million row table.
So you can use it from any
language and from anywhere.
Speaking of App Engine, as you
know App Engine has been
around for a number of years and
provides a scalable, very
easy to use, managed way to
build applications without the
hassle of managing servers.
It now has over 3 million active
applications, active
running applications, making
it one of the top Google
services, and has thriving
communities around
Python, Java, Go.
But it's missing one of the most
popular languages on the
web, one that powers 3/4
of all websites.
Well, starting today, PHP
developers can get the
benefits of App Engine.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
URS HOELZLE: This isn't like
your existing PHP stacks.
So with App Engine, you don't
have to manage your PHP stack.
We patch it and manage
for you.
And because it's App Engine, if
your site gets no traffic,
it costs you nothing.
But if your site gets
a lot of traffic, we
can scale it up fast.
And by fast, I mean fast.
We scale up new instances
in fractions of a
second, not in minutes.
And these instances
are not shared.
They are securely isolated.
Static caching is built in.
The data use store is
automatically replicated
between multiple data centers.
So this isn't your daddy's
PHP server.
In fact, just this weekend,
literally, this weekend, we
helped someone port their
existing PHP website to App
Engine PHP, because they were
anticipating a flash crowd,
which in fact did happen.
It took only a few hours to port
to site including turning
on Page Speed service.
And the result was that they
had a highly scalable site,
where a cold page load was four
times faster than before.
So PHP has never been easier
to use and run.
Speaking of App Engine, still,
a lot of you write large
applications on App Engine.
And we've made it much easier,
now, to have such large
applications.
Because you can build modules
inside your applications.
And these modules logically
separate your code.
They let you develop, with
independent teams.
And you can, at a fine-grained
level, control the versioning,
the ACLs, the updates, the
[? codas ?], and so on of
these different modules.
And in fact, you can use
different languages for these
different modules, all in
the same application.
And they all share the same
backend datastores.
So writing large applications
in App Engine
has never been easier.
Well, actually, it can
get even easier.
As you saw in the keynote, this
morning, we're making it
even easier to write
mobile backends.
Many of you already are using
the Google Cloud, as a
backend, for mobile
applications.
And with the tools you saw this
morning, in Android, in
the keynote, we're making it
even easier for you to
interface with your backend
and to generate a
lot of code for it.
You'll see that later in this.
You'll see it live, later
in this talk.
But we know that some of
you actually don't want
to write any code.
So we also are introducing the
Mobile Starter Kit, which is,
literally, a no-server
code solution.
You get a backend, a mobile
backend, with push
notifications and
authentication.
And you don't have to
write any code.
Well, you do have to write code,
namely the code for your
client, that's the code
you want to write.
No overhead, the cloud really
doesn't get easier than this.
Finally, last but not least, we
know that a lot of you care
about security.
And in fact, a lot of
organizations require their
infrastructure to
be certified.
So I'm happy to announce that
we have ISO 27K security
certification for all of our
cloud, Compute Engine, App
Engine, and storage.
And this is just one example of
our commitment to security.
And you'll hear more about
that later this year.
But now, let's see this cloud
platform in action.
So Greg will show you how easy
it is to build an application,
by mixing and matching the
different components of our
infrastructure.
Greg.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Thanks, Urs.
As Urs mentioned, I'm going
to spend the next 25 or so
minutes building out an
application that uses some of
these new features of the
cloud platform that we
announced today.
And because this is a developer
conference, we're
going to spend the next 25
minutes looking at code.
I also want to introduce Brian
Lynch, a solutions architect,
on the cloud platform, who's
going to help us as we go
through this.
So let me start by describing to
you what this application,
that we're going to build, is.
We're going to build
a video sharing
site for I/O attendees.
This is going to have a site
that allows us to upload
videos, view videos,
comment on them.
And it's going to have
a mobile companion,
as well, for us.
So let's start by looking at the
architecture we're going
to use to build this
application.
It is going to be a web
front-end that's written in
App Engine, that does
the heavy lifting.
We're going to use a variety of
data storage technologies,
from Cloud SQL to the Cloud
Datastore, to cloud storage.
There's some processing
we're going to do
with Compute Engine.
And I'll talk about that
when we get to it.
And then, finally, we're going
to build a mobile front-end,
using the Android tools, to tie
the whole thing together.
So let's start with the
App Engine front-end.
As Urs mentioned, App Engine was
originally built to take
away the tedious, error prone,
grunt work from making a
global scale, highly available
application.
It's hugely successful, with 3
million active applications.
And as Urs mentioned, there's
big communities, around the
Java and Go and Python and now
we've added PHP to the mix.
So we're going to use PHP
to build this particular
application.
So let's take a look at
PHP on App Engine.
We'll switch over to
the demo machine.
And what we have here
is a laptop with
the Cloud SDK installed.
We're going to use my favorite
text editor,
in this case, Sublime.
And we're going to start by
creating, sort of, a Hello
World application, the simplest
PHP application we
can think of.
So we'll put the PHP tag, and
we'll do a call phpinfo.
For those of you who don't know
PHP, phpinfo basically
returns a bunch of information
about the environment you're
running in, the server
environment, the
configuration, and all that.
So it's one line of code
that will generate
some interesting content.
Now, as Urs mentioned, we are
striving for a 100% compatible
version of PHP here.
So for many, many applications,
there are
absolutely no code changes.
But App Engine actually adds
extra value on top of PHP.
So let's look a little bit at
the configuration information
that we need to provide
for App Engine.
Some of this is what you'd
expect for App Engine, the
project ID, the name.
Those of you use App Engine,
know that App Engine provides
built-in support for versioning
and rollbacks, so
you can deploy new versions
of an application.
If they don't work.
You can roll them
back instantly.
So we've given this
a version number.
We've put index.php as the
name of the script
that this will run.
So with that, we've built
our application.
Let's flip over to
the terminal.
And we will publish
that app using the
standard App Engine tool.
We'll tell it that the
runtime for this
particular project is PHP.
And we'll give it
the name of it.
And up it goes.
So App Engine is collecting
the resources.
It's compiling the PHP.
It's uploading all of that
into the application.
It checks for the deployment
to work.
Sure enough, and the app
is up and running.
So let's pop over to the browser
and look at this.
So here's the PHP info.
It has all of the information
that we would expect.
That we are running on Linux.
Later on down, it will list the
version of the frameworks
that are installed.
I'll point out the server API
line showing that this is
actually running on an App
Engine PHP server.
So that's a "hello world", but
now let's actually turn around
and build our application.
And what's PHP without SQL?
Luckily, with the cloud
platform, we have
Google Cloud SQL.
Cloud SQL is a cloud hosted
service that marries the
industry standard, MySQL
front-end, to a highly
available backend, all running
on Google managed, Google
hosted infrastructure.
As a developer, I don't have
to worry about configuring
this MySQL.
I don't have to worry about
deploying it, maintaining it.
I just use industry standard
tools, like JDBC, Crystal
Reports, SQuirreL SQL
to manage it.
So to help get us started, we
pre-populated a Cloud SQL
database with some videos that
we took in the week running up
to the conference.
So let's take a look at that.
We're going to switch over
to our command line.
We're going to use the Cloud
SQL command tools.
And I'm going to specify the
name of the project and the
name of the instance, of Cloud
SQL, that I'm running on, and
then the particular database
I want to look at.
So we have connection.
And now I can use just standard
MySQL-type commands.
We'll show the tables.
You'll see that there's
a table of
videos, a table of users.
We'll select the first, I don't
know, 10 or 50 videos
from the videos table.
And what I want to point
out here is, of
course, there's an ID.
You'll notice that what's stored
here is a URL into
Google Cloud Storage.
We're actually storing these
videos in cloud storage.
So let's actually start to build
out the application to
query these.
To make it a little bit simpler,
we're going to switch
over to the desktop.
And I'm going to drag and drop
in a bunch of CSS and HTML and
JavaScript to make the
application look pretty.
And we're going to look at one
particular bit of code, which
is the code that queries
the MySQL database.
If you know PHP, this code
should look very, very
familiar to you.
This is standard PHP MySQL code,
the standard connection
string and a standard query.
But there are advantages of
running with Cloud SQL.
We know that this App Engine
app and this Cloud SQL are
part of the same project,
because you told us that.
That allows us to automatically
configure the
firewalls to allow those two to
talk to each other, while
keeping them isolated from
other traffic and other
projects that are running
on the infrastructure.
It also allows us to place
those instances, in our
infrastructure, in a way that
reduces latency between them.
Because, again, we know that
this particular Cloud SQL
database and this particular
application are running with
each other.
So let's go ahead and
run this app.
And so now I've got my nice
pretty CSS and HTML.
We've retrieved, from the
database, the URLs, the
thumbnails for all the videos.
So we'll just pick one
at random there.
And were retrieving the video.
And there's Joe waving at us.
So that's a simple use of
querying a Cloud SQL database.
Now this is a video site.
And it is 2013.
So, clearly, I have to have
comments on a video, right?
In fact, I expect this site
to be wildly popular.
I think I might have thousands
of comments for every video.
And I have thousands
of videos.
So clearly, I need a very low
latency, high performance
datastore to hold
those comments.
Now, fortunately, we have Cloud
Datastore, our built-in
NoSQL database.
As Urs mentioned, we're
currently handling over 4 and
1/2 trillion requests a month.
I think that's enough
scalability for the comments
we're going to process.
So let's take a look at that.
We flip over.
This is a little bit of code,
from App Engine, that accesses
the comments in the
Cloud Datastore.
You'll notice, again, it looks
very familiar to you if you're
a PHP developer.
It's retrieving a little
bit of information
from the HTML page.
So it's getting the comment.
It's retrieving a little bit
of information from the
session state, so I know the
name of the logged in user.
It's constructing a
comment entity.
It's putting in the text, the
current date, the user, and
then it's calling the PUT method
to actually take that
data and store it into
Cloud Datastore.
Once it's stored, if we scroll
down a little bit farther,
we'll see the code
to retrieve it.
It's creating a query
for the comment.
It's filtering it
by the video ID.
It's ordering it by the
date it was added.
And then it's actually taking
that and putting it
into the HTML page.
So we already have some
comments we added.
So let's flip back over
and see what people
think of Joe's waving.
And they seem to like it.
So Brian, what do you
think of Joe's wave?
BRIAN LYNCH: Great.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Great wave.
Great.
So when he hits Enter, we'll
create that, post it into the
datastore, pull it back,
and there we have it.
So now we have App Engine
accessing a very, highly
available, highly scalable,
global datastore.
So let me flip back to
the slides for a sec.
Let me sort of recap what
we've done so far.
We've built the front-end, using
PHP, the language the
powers 3/4 of the world's
websites.
We've accessed data in
a variety of forms.
We've queried a database, in
Cloud SQL, using just the
plain, old PHP MySQL integration
that I'm used to.
I've used cloud storage to
access, potentially, terabytes
of data that I've stored
in actual videos.
We've used a NoSQL database,
in the Cloud Datastore, to
store and update comments.
So that's a pretty good
front-end so far.
But you know, behind most of the
most popular websites out
there, somewhere, there
is some heavy duty
processing going on.
That could be analyzing
log files.
It could be building
recommendation engines, to
tell you that, if you like
a, you might like b.
It could be processing media,
whether it's audio or video.
In our case, we want to allow
our users to upload the
videos, in any format, and then
we want to transcode that
to a variety of formats, for
a variety of devices.
That sort of work is a really
good task for Compute Engine.
It's spiky computationally,
right?
So it only happens
when somebody
actually uploads a video.
It actually is CPU intensive.
And so it's the kind of task
where I want the cores I want,
when I want them, and with
the performance I expect.
So it's a really good job
for Compute Engine.
Since the last I/O, we've been
very busy hardening the
Compute Engine service,
rolling out new
capabilities for it.
So let me give you an update
of what Compute
Engine looks like.
So let's switch back to
our cloud console.
And this is, for those you who
have noticed already, we've
rolled out a new version
of the Cloud Console.
Compute Engine now
appears in it.
I think the console
looks great.
So let's first show you the user
interface for creating a
new instance.
So to create an instance, I
populate it with all the
things you'd expect.
I give it a name, a region.
I apply metadata to it.
If Brian scrolls down, we look
at the machine types.
We've been busy expanding
the range of
machine types we offer.
So we have everything from one
to eight cores, with the
disks, without disks, high
memory, high CPU.
So pretty much whatever the type
of load you have, we've
got a machine type there
that's suited for it.
Now, in our case, we're not
going to create VMs with the
user interface.
We're going to create them
programmatically
via the REST API.
Because we're going to have App
Engine orchestrate these
virtual machines.
App Engine is going to be the
one that creates VMs as we
need them and kills them when
we don't need them anymore.
And for everything you do in the
Cloud Console, there's a
corresponding REST API
that lets you do it.
So we've got a quick
upload page,
here, that we've created.
And it's a simple HTML
target that allows me
to drag videos in.
Now, we could drag one video
in and watch what happens.
But one video?
I mean that's not really Google
scale, is it, right?
You guys just saw maps
of the Earth.
So I think you expect a little
more than one video.
So let's drop 1,000 in.
Now VMs take 20 to 30 seconds
to spin up, which may seems
fast to you, but, to us,
that's still too slow.
But while it does that, let me
just talk to you about what
it's doing.
We could have App Engine just
fire up one VM and tell it,
encode 1,000 videos.
But that would take a while.
What I really want to do is
have a fleet of virtual
machines that I spread
the work out to.
And that's exactly what the App
Engine app is doing here.
It's firing up a bank of VMs.
It's using our Compute Engine
management APIs to
monitor the CPU load.
If the CPU loads are all busy,
it fires up more VMs, so the
job gets done quickly.
If the CPU load drops, it gives
that VM more jobs to do.
When it's finally done, it goes
through and it shuts down
all the VMs, so that I don't
pay for the usage any more.
And this is a good example of
why fast start-up and sub-hour
billing is so cool.
I can literally throw cores at
a problem, because the VMs
start-up quickly.
They do the work.
And I only pay for the
minutes that I'm
actually running them.
So I think, by this time,
we should have
some VMs up and running.
So let's pop back over
to the console.
And you'll notice, down there,
there's the list of our VMs.
They're in alphabetical order,
not the order we
instantiated them.
So if we scroll down, yeah, you
see the green check marks.
Those are VMs that are up
and running and are
processing work now.
And if you scroll back up to the
graph, you'll see that we
ran an earlier test run,
a little bit earlier.
And you can see the
CPU spikes, from
those, jumping up.
And more importantly, you see
them going back to 0 when the
work was done.
You know, at Google, we
say faster is better.
And we certainly take that to
heart in Compute Engine, by
having fast start-up times,
consistent performance, and
sub-hour billing, really letting
you do things that
weren't even economically
possible before.
So let me go back to the slides
for a sec, recap where
we are, with our application.
We've got a front-end, written
in App Engine and PHP, that
handles all the website.
We've got a variety of
datastores in cloud storage,
Cloud SQL, Cloud Datastore.
And we have a backend in Compute
Engine that does video
encoding for us.
But there's more we can do
with Compute Engine here.
Remember, I talked about those
comments that we've had in the
Cloud Datastore?
Well, as the owner this site,
I'd like to actually know
whether, on balance,
those comments were
good, bad, or neutral.
And then furthermore, I want
to use Compute Engine to do
that analysis.
Now, in the past, the Cloud
Datastore was only available
to App Engine.
But as of today, that
Datastore is open to
everybody, so that I can access
the same comments data
that App Engine was using
from Compute Engine.
The nice thing about the
Datastore, it was developed
for the kind of data sets that
we encounter at Google.
Because we do things like Web
Search and Maps and ads and
Gmail, we needed a very high
capacity datastore that had
very fast performance.
So you get consistent
performance on this Datastore,
whether you're accessing
a megabyte of data or
a terabyte of data.
So let's flip over and look at
how we're going to do this.
We wrote a Python script that
analyzes the comments.
We'll take a quick look.
So we're going to SSH
into that machine.
So why don't we go back to the
text editor, real quick, so we
can show the code.
So this is just some very simple
analysis, based on the
words that are included in the
post, to find out whether it's
net positive or negative.
If we scroll down a bit,
we'll see the code
to query the database.
So there's query response equals
database dot run query.
That retrieves the data.
And then there's some similar
code that writes the data,
such as datastore.BlindWrite.
In this case, we're the only
ones accessing the Datastore.
So a BlindWrite is just fine.
I don't have to worry about
multiple writers.
If I did care about that, I
could just as easily wrap this
up in a transaction and get that
transacted protection as
well as this way.
So this is our simple video
comment analysis.
Let's go back and actually run
it, on one video, to see what
it does, for one video.
So we're SSH-ed into our
virtual machine.
And we're going to run
this Python script.
And it retrieves all the
comments, very, very quickly.
For each comment, it determines
0 is neutral, 1 is
positive, minus 1 is negative.
Now, that's fine
for one video.
But I've got 1,000 videos.
And I have 1,000 comments
on each video.
So this starts to look like
a MapReduce sort of
job, doesn't it, right?
Phase one being, analyzing
all the comments.
Phase two being to collect that
information and come up
with an aggregate answer
of whether a
video is good or bad.
So we already have a 10 node
Hadoop cluster up and running
on Compute Engine.
And just to prove that this
really is writing to the
Datastore, let me flip over to
the Datastore Viewer, in the
Cloud Console, and we'll look
at the comments Datastore.
So we've got a query written.
So just to see, these are all
the IDs of the videos and the
number of comments they have.
And you'll notice there's no
column there for a sentiment.
We haven't yet calculated
that.
In fact, because this is a NoSQL
database, we don't even
have a schema for columns.
In fact, if I were using
a SQL database, this
would be really difficult.
Because I would have to push
a schema change through the
whole system, just to start
calculating sentiments.
The nice thing about NoSQL
databases is you just start
writing new values, and they
automatically appear.
So let's fire up the Hadoop
job, and let's start
processing these for
all of the videos.
Now, as Urs mentioned,
we run a lot of
MapReduce inside of Google.
So we've really tried to
optimize our data center to
run MapReduce jobs
really well.
So our job is running.
The map phase, for each video,
it retrieves all the comments.
It does a quick analysis on
whether it's positive,
negative, or neutral.
The reduce phase then collects
those results, for all the
videos, and comes up with
an answer for each one.
So the map is done.
The reduce has started.
So let's flip back to the
console and re-run the query.
And you'll notice, we have
total sentiments now
calculated.
It's a new column
that appeared.
We've calculated all that.
Some of them looks awesome.
Some videos got a 31.
Some of them, maybe
not so much.
I hope Joe is the 31 and
not the minus 4.
So sure enough, the values
are calculated.
And they appear in
the Datastore.
So if we go and look at--
the last thing we did was we
updated our PHP page to
actually retrieve that value
that was calculated.
So if you scroll down, you'll
see it's now positive.
So here we had App
Engine entering
comments in the Datastore.
Compute Engine reading those
values, writing a sentiment
value back.
And then App Engine seeing that
sentiment and placing it
in the page.
So you really get to use each
service, for the job it's best
at, but have a consistent set
of datastores that you can
access across all of those.
So let's flip back
to the slides.
So that completes our web app.
Let's turn our attention to
the mobile companion.
We're all walking around with
incredibly powerful, video
devices in our pockets.
So of course, we want
to be able to take
video and upload them.
And in fact, what I really want
to do is make it super
easy, for my mobile developers,
to access the code
that I've written inside
of App Engine.
And Cloud Endpoints does that.
Cloud Endpoints makes it super
simple to write backend logic,
in whatever language you want,
and easily expose a nice,
friendly, client
side interface.
You don't have to worry about
data sterilization.
You don't have to write
OAuth code.
You simply write server code.
And then you get a nice,
client library for it.
So to do that, we've written
some backend code, in Java,
taking advantage of the feature,
that Urs talked
about, of breaking App Engine
apps into sub-components.
We've written a second
component in Java.
We need to switch
the switcher.
This component does
two things.
First, it returns a URL into
Cloud Storage, for the mobile
device, to upload to.
Second, it provides an API,
here, you see, called Upload
Completed, that the mobile
device will call when the
video is uploaded.
And when that's done, the App
Engine server sets a title,
creates a thumbnail, basically
populates the metadata about
that video.
So I'm pretty happy.
That does what I want.
Now, those of you have noticed,
will notice that
we're not in Sublime anymore.
This is the new Android Studio
Mobile IDE that you heard
announced, earlier today.
Based on IntelliJ, I think it's
a huge step forward, in
terms of providing a
great development
environment for Android.
Now, I'm a cloud guy, so my
particular favorite feature
here is this.
I can Right Click on
my server project.
And down there, there's
Cloud Endpoints.
And it says, Generate
Client Libraries.
That's all I need to do.
The tool will then generate, for
me, a client side wrapper
that gives me a nice, clean,
type-safe interface to my
server side logic.
So let's look at that
client side code.
And you'll notice this code
looks very much like the
server side code.
There's Upload Completed.
It takes a bunch of parameters
for a URL and a
thumbnail and a string.
So by calling that, I don't
have to deal with the
authentication.
I don't have to worry about how
do I serialize and marshal
data back and forth between
the client and the server.
So we're actually going to run
this application, now.
I've got an Android
phone, here.
So if we switch over to this.
Hello?
Is the phone bad?
The phone turned off.
You rehearse for almost every
eventuality in these things,
but, somehow, the phone being
turned off is not one of them.
While that's coming up, let me
mention a couple things.
There are breakout sessions on
all the topics that we're
covering today, including mobile
development, with the
backend starter.
PHP on App Engine, there's
a complete break
out session on that.
There's a breakout session on
the Cloud Datastore as well.
So if you want the nitty gritty,
from the developers,
on any of those technologies,
definitely those breakout
sessions are where to go.
I don't have my phone here.
BRIAN LYNCH: One second,
[INAUDIBLE].
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Toss me
my phone, from my bag.
I have the app on it.
Battery?
So we'll take one more time
for that to boot.
I'm going to go through this,
because it's worth seeing the
mobile device.
There we go.
There we are.
Unfortunately, I'm about
to expose Brian's--
excuse me--
unlock code, so if you happen to
get his phone, you now know
how to do all sorts of things.
So here's our application.
It's staring up at the Elmo.
I'm going to put
my head in it.
I'm going to hit the
record button.
You'll see, it starts
recording.
You'll see the blue recording
bar going across.
It's finished recording.
Connecting to server for URL.
So it's making the first call.
Could not upload your video.
Let's try it one more time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Yep.
Ah, yes, now we have
a connection.
Let's see how Verizon does.
There we go.
So it's recording now.
Connecting to server.
Uploading the video.
Yes!
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Persistence
pays off.
I'm going to do one more of
you guys, just so you're
memorialized, in my keynote
demo, for the time when my
phone didn't work,
of all things.
So I'm taking a video now.
Everybody can wave.
Very nice.
And it's going to do its thing,
connecting to the
server, uploading the video.
Let's flip back to
the actual site.
Let's look at the videos.
The most recent one uploaded
is, yes, me, looking,
unfortunately, right
up my nose.
If my parents are watching,
I apologize now.
Oh, there we go.
That's a better one.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Let's
go back to slides.
So that's, really, just one
example of what you can do
with the Cloud Platform.
I want to point out one more,
that I'm not going to build,
but I want to draw your
attention to.
And this is the Data
Sensing Lab.
Those of you who have noticed
have seen these little signs
around Mosconi Center.
We've deployed 525 sensors
around Mosconi that measure
things, such as the temperature
and the humidity
and sensor maps of how many
people are walking by and the
noise level, how loud is it.
And then we've built a system,
using the Cloud Platform, to
collect that data, to store that
data, to analyze it, and
to visualize it.
So if you go to the Sandbox,
right now, after this session,
you'll be able to see this data
in realtime and sort of
play with and visualize a very
large, very rich set of data.
There's also going to be a
session, where the authors of
the Data Sensing Lab will walk
you through what they did, how
they did it, and how they
used the cloud platform.
While you're at the Sandbox,
please take the time to stop
by and look at our partners.
As you know, even as much effort
as we put into the
Cloud Platform, it's
not just us.
It's also our partners that
help make this real.
In particular, there
are 16 partners who
will be in our sand--
[LOSS OF AUDIO]
Somebody Double Clicked
the button.
They'll be 16 partners
in the Sandbox.
These aren't marketing people.
These are developers.
So you can go and ask your
technical questions.
They'll tell you their best
practices they learned from
running on the Cloud Platform.
And so that's a great
resource as well.
With that, we'll turn
it back over to Urs.
And I'll wish everybody,
have a great I/O.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
URS HOELZLE: Thank you, Greg.
So you've heard a lot
today and saw a lot
of cool, new things.
Just to recap, you've seen the
Cloud Datastore, in action, in
the demos, and accessible,
now, from anywhere.
You have sub-hour billing, so
you pay only for what you
actually use.
You have shared core instances,
for the times where
you just need a little
bit of CPU.
You have Advanced Routing to
connect on-premise and
off-premise.
You have 10 times larger
persistent disks.
And you have PHP
on App Engine.
But there's one more thing
I'd like to talk about.
And in fact, it's something that
I wish we had had in 1999
when we started Google.
And it's something that
we've been working on
for a very long time.
And it's something that's just a
start, but something that, I
believe, will change the face
of computing over the next
decade, based on the work that
we've done in the past decade.
Something that will make Google
better but will make
the lives of developers better,
and it will make the
web better.
So I'm very, very excited that
tonight, starting at 6:00 PM,
Compute Engine is open, for
signups, to everyone.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
URS HOELZLE: So head over to
cloud.google.com, sign up,
give it as spin.
I'm excited to see what
all of you do
on top of this platform.
So thank you for coming to
Google I/O. Thanks for coming
to the Cloud Session.
Have fun at the other
sessions.
And have fun in San Francisco.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]